welcome back Aroma retail the sponsors
of this segment want to help make your
Valentine's Day fragrant Rocky spot stop
by there's smelly bar to learn how
Love is in the air at the smelly bar we
have everything you need to send your
space along with more than 90 different
fragrances any way you want to deploy it
we're running this together this
we can offer you especially now that
we're coming up on Valentine's Day a lot
of little smelly things that can uh you
know put you in touch with your sweetie
and get closer start by asking yourself
what scent reminds you of your Valentine
for example hello Noir is sexy like me
yeah and then we also have fragrances
that are beautiful like humor though and
no matter what scent you choose Aroma
retail gift baskets are a great way to
help you diffuse love on Valentine's Day
and Beyond this is our smallest one here
and it has a lot of goodies inside it
says our wax candle melter it has a set
of our mix and match it has oh it has
the linen spray when you want to freshen
up maybe the bedroom or the couch for
Valentine's Day I think it also has the
four ounce bottles in any fragrance you
want yeah the four ounce the four ounce
bottle actually refills our scent
machine home Unit 101 which is also a
great gift on its own for scenting the
whole home speaking of our scent
machines we also have our little set
machine travel fits in the cup holder in
your car it's got a setting for car
office or home where it could run a lot
or a little bit depending on the size of
space and it's completely completely
portable doesn't have to be plugged in
all the time on the other side of the
spectrum we've got our set machine
professional this is the one that can
connect to your ventilation system or be
freestanding but this consent just about
any space like we're talking up to 10
000 square feet or of course a smaller
space and the oil lasts a lot longer
speaking of long lasting Jim and
Christina have been married for 14 years
so Aroma retail knows a thing or two
about keeping the candle burning you
know these fragrances really they set
the mood we have we have a whole mood
collection where we focus on different
moods but most important to me is just
love it brought us together it did our
fragrances brought us together in
running this company but we also you
know we're constantly cognizant of what
scent should we run in the house this
month or whatever what do we want to
feel like absolutely because sense are
so important for our well-being and for
our moods for our happiness and and so
this could be the the gift that keeps on
giving and for whatever time then
Valentine's Day to uh to actually share
that with our loved ones
thank you Aroma retail for sponsoring
this segment for more information call
702-780-7370 or visit aromare.com they
have a special offer for you visit the
smelly bar and mention Channel 8 for 20
off we'll be right back